[Música]
una nueva página en la relación entre
Francia y Reino Unido en el Palacio del
Eliseo Emanuel macron y Richi sunak
acordaron reforzar la cooperación en
materia energética de apoyo militar a
kiev y de control de fronteras en el
Canal de la Mancha tenemos análisis en
esta edición
Irán y Arabia Saudita dos rivales
históricos de medio oriente restablecen
relaciones diplomáticas
volverán a abrir sus respectivas
embajadas cerradas en 2016 y reactivan
su acuerdo de cooperación en seguridad
las autoridades alemanas confirman que
el autor del tiroteo de Hamburgo se
suicidó durante el ataque en un centro
de Testigos de Jehová la policía Indicó
que además del atacante murieron siete
personas
Buenas tardes bienvenidos las noticias
de France 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
masdeu y es para mí un gusto
acompañarles abrimos esta ronda
informativa en Francia porque el
presidente francés y el Primer Ministro
británico acordaron reforzar la
cooperación en materia de control de
fronteras energía y apoyo militar a
Ucrania reunidos en el Palacio del
Eliseo macrón y sunak escenificaron un
encuentro que no se producía desde hace
5 años Durante los cuales las relaciones
entre Londres y París se han visto
degradadas por el brexit o por el
acuerdo militar ocus ahora para analizar
la cita conectamos con el analista de
relaciones internacionales y académico
de la Universidad de cardif César
Jiménez
César Buenas tardes para usted empiezo
preguntando por qué se produce ahora
este encuentro después de años sin una
reunión bilateral
bueno Primero gracias por la invitación
esto hay que verlo dentro del contexto
de la administración de rishizuna que
está intentando normalizar las
relaciones con con Europa
Richi es una que está tratando de
de darle un caris distintos a su
administración más allá de la de las
diferencias que había con Johnson y y la
administración del Entonces es el
contexto Esto no es anclado esto también
es parte de del acuerdo de de Windsor
Entonces es una cuestión de intentar
normalizar las relaciones que tiene el
Reino Unido con Europa con el desafío
Eso sí de también tener que mantener
contento a los votantes más de derecha
que es el desafío que tiene actualmente
y le preguntó a grandes rasgos en que se
traducirán que se materializará esta
nueva cooperación entre París y Londres
Bueno hay acuerdos en términos de
seguridad hay acuerdos también en
términos de cooperación de energía pero
lo que ha llamado más la atención en
términos noticiosos en el Reino Unido es
el acuerdo concreto el anuncio que se
hizo de que el Reino Unido va a entregar
500 millones de libras esterlinas al
gobierno francés para construir un
centro de detención en el norte de
Francia cerca de dunker ese ha sido el
principal anuncio que se ha recogido y
es lo que enfatizado también gobierno
británico dentro de el Reino Unido dado
todas la la la la la la la la atención
noticiosa que ha recibido en el Reino
Unido el hecho de que han llegado más
refugiados a este país Yo diría que ese
es el principal anuncio lo que hay que
esperar es cómo va a ser recibido ese
anuncio dentro del Reino Unido si va a
ser visto como parte de
un fortalecimiento de las fronteras del
Reino Unido que es lo que los votantes
conservadores están pidiendo
si se está viendo como otra prueba más
de que el Reino Unido no tiene control
sobre sus fronteras y depende de otros
países para controlar la situación
quisiera recoger un par de cuestiones
que usted ha destacado por un lado la
importancia no de este nuevo centro de
atención en las costas francesas del
Canal de la Mancha que financiará en
gran parte el Reino Unido Y es que
precisamente tanto Emmanuel macron como
Richie sunak comparten esta digamos dura
retórica contra la migración clandestina
con el proyecto de ley que propuso el
partido conservador británico esta misma
semana que algunas organizaciones han
calificado de atentar incluso contra el
derecho internacional al asilo Pero
además macron y sunat comparten un
pasado una carrera en el mundo de las
finanzas le pregunto si ambos
mandatarios digamos comparten una misma
visión del mundo y esto facilita el
entendimiento entre ambos
en principio las relaciones parecen
tener como como tú bien dice una una
base común de hecho se habla acá en esta
tarde los medios británicos han hablado
de el romance entre Richi sunak y Manuel
macron precisamente por las
características que tú dices creo que si
bien
pueden tener y compartir una visión de
mundo con respecto a temas por ejemplo
con migración que tú dices eh sunat
tiene en este momento un desafío mucho
más grande
estaba mirando algunos comentarios en la
prensa británica y
algunos de los votantes conservadores no
están de acuerdo con lo que está
haciendo es una que sienten que debería
tener una retórica mucho más dura
todavía que ven que el acuerdo con con
Francia es un acuerdo blando y preferían
que incluso fuese mucho más extremo en
términos de retórica y acciones Entonces
es una básicamente están haciendo un
acto de equilibrio por un lado tratando
de normalizar las relaciones con Europa
Pero por otro lado tratando de mantener
contentos a posibles votantes que
teniendo en cuenta las elecciones
generales del próximo año
Jiménez entonces iremos viendo como
evolucionan estas nuevas relaciones
Muchísimas gracias por su tiempo y por
su análisis Muchas gracias
nosotros cambiamos de información porque
en China el mismo día Queen revalidó su
tercer mandato presidencial Irán y
Arabia Saudita restablecieron relaciones
tras siete años de ruptura diplomática
reunidos en Beijing en presencia del
máximo diplomático chino wangie
representantes de las dos principales
potencias chivita y sunita comunicaron
un acuerdo que incluye la reapertura de
embajadas en los respectivos territorios
en un plazo de dos meses Terán yriat
apoyan facciones opuestas en varios
países de oriente medio Como yemen así
que aseguran que reactivar su
cooperación en materia de seguridad
ayudará a la estabilidad Regional de
hecho el líder de gesbolá ya saludo la
noticia repasemos ahora las relaciones
entre ambas potencias con el siguiente
informe
enero de 2016 read anunció a la ruptura
de sus relaciones diplomáticas con
Teherán luego de que manifestantes
iraníes atacaran las misiones
diplomáticas saudíes en Irán tras la
ejecución en el reino de un clérico
disidente
el régimen iraní tiene un largo
historial de violaciones contra misiones
diplomáticas extranjeras como la
ocupación de la embajada estadounidense
en 1979 o el ataque a la embajada
británica en 2011 y finalmente ayer el
ataque contra la embajada Saudita entera
y su consulado general en massadt
el fin
esto provocó el estallido de grandes
manifestaciones en Irán y el
empeoramiento de las relaciones entre
ambos países lo que llevó a Teherán a
acusar a Arabia Saudita de
desestabilizar la región y contribuir a
la propagación del terrorismo
el asesinato de esta persona y el
martirio de una persona de realmente un
crimen es un gran crimen ya aquellos que
toman las decisiones en el gobierno
Saudita no deberían tener ninguna duda
de que esta sangre les causará problemas
la República islámica y el reino de
Arabia Saudita son las dos potencias más
destacadas de la región el más notable
el de yemen donde era una coalición
militar que apoya al gobierno reconocido
internacionalmente
y acusa a Teherán de apoyar a los
sutiles que controlan grandes áreas en
el norte del país sobre todo sana Arabia
Saudita también está preocupada por el
programa nuclear de Irán y sus
capacidades de misiles expresa su
preocupación por la influencia Regional
de Teherán y lo acusa de interferir en
Países Árabes como Irak Siria y Líbano
el presidente Turco
erdogan firmó ya el decreto de
convocatoria de elecciones
presidenciales y legislativas con lo que
confirmó que los comicios se celebrarán
según lo previsto el próximo 14 de mayo
las elecciones llegan en un momento de
horas bajas de la popularidad del actual
mandatario el país está sumido en una
larga crisis económica y la sociedad
mantiene fresco el recuerdo de los
terremotos que causaron la muerte de más
de 52.000 personas a principios de
febrero por otro lado recordemos que el
pasado martes la coalición turca de
oposición presentó ya a su candidato
presidencial se trata del líder de la
principal formación opositora el partido
republicano
Para sanar las heridas de nuestros
damnificados por el terremoto para
borrar todo rastro del desastre
para reconstruir nuestras ciudades Para
volver a incrementar la producción y el
empleo es fundamental que nuestro país
deje atrás cuanto antes la agenda
electoral
este entendimiento y con la autoridad
que nos otorga la Constitución estamos
implementando nuestra decisión
previamente anunciada de llamar a las
elecciones el 14 de mayo
y actualizamos ahora las noticias sobre
el ataque en Hamburgo Alemania las
autoridades confirmaron que ya son siete
las víctimas mortales del tiroteo masivo
en un centro de Testigos de Jehová la
policía alemana Indicó que el agresor se
quitó la vida luego de la intervención
de las autoridades aún continúan Las
investigaciones para determinar el móvil
del crimen a esta hora nuestro
corresponsal en Alemania Thomas Sparrow
con los últimos detalles
hay conmoción entre muchos alemanes tras
el tiroteo del jueves en la noche en
Hamburgo en especial Porque son poco
comunes los tiroteos en Alemania en
comparación con otros países las
autoridades explicaron este viernes en
una rueda de prensa que según la
información que han podido recabar el
presunto atacante no tenía una
motivación política ni el tiroteo un
trasfondo terrorista si bien es cierto
que las investigaciones continúan más
bien todo parece indicar que las
investigaciones están centrando en un
posible problema de Salud Mental del
atacante o en problemas personales del
atacante con la comunidad de los
Testigos de Jehová a la que había
pertenecido antes de salir de ella de
mala manera las autoridades también
explicaron este viernes que el presunto
atacante había obtenido su arma de
manera legal lo que está generando todo
tipo de preguntas en Alemania sobre cómo
es posible que haya podido obtener un
arma teniendo en cuenta por un lado que
Alemania considerado uno de los países
con las leyes deporte de armas más
estrictas y por el otro lado sabiendo
que como dijeron las propias autoridades
habían recibido una información anónima
antes del ataque advirtiendo de un
posible problema de Salud Mental del
atacante así las cosas Las
investigaciones continúan y también
continúa y probablemente crecerá el
debate político en Alemania tras el
ataque tras el tiroteo del jueves en la
noche en Hamburgo
y en France 24 continuamos conmemorando
el día internacional por los derechos de
la mujer y lo hacemos con nuestra serie
de distintas historias en América Latina
hoy vamos a Ecuador donde una asociación
de defensa de los derechos de la mujer
ha planteado La regulación de la
actividad sexual y la protección de los
derechos de quienes la ejercen Lourdes
Torres ayuda a mujeres dedicadas a este
oficio y también a sus familias nuestro
corresponsal Gustavo Ortega nos cuenta
la historia
ayudamos a las personas mujeres
positivas con VIH Lourdes Torres líder
de la asociación prodefensa de la mujer
se declara activista por los derechos de
las mujeres y busca apoyo ante la falta
de un marco jurídico de protección para
esta actividad en Ecuador mientras lo
consigue Lourdes ayuda también a las
familias de mujeres en situación de
prostitución un término que ella no
comparte y prefiere el de trabajadoras
sexuales es el caso de solange Benavides
a quien la asociación patrocinó sus
estudios luego del fallecimiento de su
madre una ex trabajadora sexual al
activismo de las trabajadoras sexuales
les debo mi educación
les debo un plato de comida que llegaba
a mi casa
mi mamá bueno con apoyo de la Señora
Lourdes Torres pudo salir del trabajo
sexual este día Lourdes asiste a una
audiencia en un tribunal de Quito para
presentar una acción de protección a
favor de cuatro mil de ellas un la
legalización y el reconocimiento del
trabajo sexual y deber de ver que la de
la situación que también seamos parte
del seguro social y también de saber que
que tenemos el mismo derecho todo para
de ser una ciudad na Que todas
[Música]
en un club nocturno funciona la
asociación María prepara la comida para
las mujeres antes de iniciar su jornada
en otro piso contiguo Natalia está a
cargo del desarrollo de programas piloto
enfocados en asesoría legal y apoyo a
quienes deseen abandonar la actividad en
el país según Natalia hay 70.000
establecimientos como los llama el
Ministerio de salud pública donde se
ejerce esta actividad la asociación
prodefensa de la mujer en sí lo que
hemos retomado es el tema de ayudar y
guiar a las chicas en el tema de
derechos Aunque la prostitución en
Ecuador no es ilegal no hay una
regulación de protección de sus derechos
sólo se practica en lugares denominados
casas de tolerancia Lourdes cuestiona
que no garantizan la integridad física
psicológica o una vida libre de
violencia cada día Estas mujeres pueden
ser Víctimas de explotación sexual o
abuso de las autoridades
y vamos así al final de este repaso
informativo pero sigan con nosotros y
más información en France 24 y 24 punto
com
[Música]